foreign
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about this is
John with the Dr John deloney show we're
talking about mental health marriage
parenting whatever's going on in your
world
so glad that you're here here's the
whole point of the show here's why we do
what we do
me and the whole team
once your marriage to be a little bit
better or maybe a lot better I want you
to be whole
not be an abusive toxic mess of
relationship or wherever you work or
financial whatever's going on in your
life
I just want you to have
peace
and that's just gone it's just gone
these days and I'm committed to bringing
it back a little by little step by step
by step by step which I think is a new
kids on the blog song I just want people
to have peace
so that's what we do I'll sit with you
in the mess and whatever's going on in
your life and we will figure out what to
do next I've been doing this for a
couple of decades and now I'm doing it
on the internet and so if you want to
join me if you want to come sit down and
have some nachos and we'll figure this
thing out give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask and
huge help if you just hit subscribe if
you will just leave the reviews click on
the Subscribe buttons it's a huge help
not only to the show but it puts it up
into the the internet algorithm things
and it puts the show in front of other
people who are struggling who are
Googling how can I get life help how can
I get out of a bad situation how can I
stop being abused how can I figure out
whatever's going on in the life and it
just kicks up in their feed and it gets
people hope shines a light in the
darkness and you can really help with
that so thank you so much for joining us
let's go to Alex in Nashville Tennessee
right down the street what's up Alex
yeah I can hear you loud and clear I can
hear you even louder and clearer I'm a
one-upper I guess I don't know why I
just said that what's up man
um well frankly I am not okay doc that's
why I'm calling you well I'm glad you
called man let's figure it out what's up
so uh just to let you know um disclaimer
basically I'm not here to talk about how
wrong my wife is uh we both have issues
that we need to deal with um okay I'll
offer to beat some pieces and the more
years I spend with my wife the more I
understand how to care for
um that's why I'm here that's why I want
to get to the bottom of this let's do it
okay so
um I've been
a little bit Background by myself I've
been sexually abused when I was about
nine years old I just was at school I
have plenty of babysitters I had no clue
that I was dropped to sleep but
sometimes
um but now I know and
for from uncontrollable sexual thoughts
uh fear doubt broken self-esteem
there'll be some days when I come home
I'll be fine and some days I'll be just
terrible terrible
um if it wasn't for my family though
like later on in the days I probably
would have been a psychiatric Facility
by now so have you have you received
Mental Health Care over the years
uh not necessarily I went to a counselor
here and there but
um it it always backlashes uh with uh
with my current uh marriage uh either we
we still have things to figure out and
I'm trying to figure out where to go
from here have you taken the aces score
okay I want you to do that right when we
get off the phone it's the adverse
childhood experiences inventory and uh
our survey and I want you to take is 10
questions it'll take you five minutes
okay
my guess is just based on what you told
me your score is probably somewhere
between six and eight if if maybe not a
little bit higher
a school a score over a four has been
demonstrated to shorten lifespan
oh if undealt with and here's why okay
it sets your body off on high alert 24 7
365 and our bodies aren't designed to go
24 7 365.
and so it slowly Cascades through
everything okay so I'm telling you that
because
um
just listening to your story you sound
like a pretty great guy whose car is
redlining and has been since he was nine
years old
yeah
is that fair
yeah that sounds about right okay all
right so we won't harp on that because
that's not why you're calling so tell me
about your marriage man
uh so
um so my wife has broken parents
um they never gave her love they never
uh spent time with her uh never
understood her uh they still uh treat
her as a child you know today
um her father was a whole like her
mother was a stay-at-home mom
she will actually take care of her
animals instead of her child and that's
just very very depressing uh but now the
anger and the regret and all those
things are showing in the relationship
and uh it's very hard because you know
like I'm a very passive man I don't
really like conflict I don't have
conflict and I I'm the kind of person to
just leave the situation rather than to
fight in the situation
um and uh
most of the time when we come to a
disagreement it just becomes very like
you know yelling anger shouting and
sometimes I just wonder why you know
like what did I do
um and it's always about what did I do
and how can I make it better uh and it
has been difficult since our marriage um
oh yeah so I'm gonna
um
foreign
I can tell that fragile isn't the right
word but I can tell that there's you've
got deep pain okay and some of the
things that I normally this conversation
if you had just said what you said and
we were in a counseling relationship it
would take a lot longer to get there
because I would need your body to
understand that I'm safe okay
because we only have a few minutes on a
phone call I'm gonna be a little more
direct than I normally would okay yeah
so I want if you if you feel your body's
starting to shut down I want you to stay
with me as best you can okay okay I'm on
I'm on your team okay
okay so my first thing I want you to
hold in this and I want you to hold it
in your hand because you probably never
held it before
people who have been sexually abused
often carry deep deep shame
okay
people who carry deep shame often not
always but often find themselves as
adults
as peacekeepers as making sure everybody
else is okay
and I want you to think of the
peacekeeping role the you instantly go
to the mirror and say what did I do how
can I make this better I'm so sorry that
you're hurting I'm so sorry that you're
mad I'm so sorry that you're loud how
can I fix this how can I fix this
I want you to think of that as a as a
selfish Act
and not as a judgment I just want you to
be curious about it
because maybe your wife's response has
absolutely nothing to do with you
and when you try to go fix something
that's spinning around inside of her
um it creates tension and chaos and
conflict here's what here here's what
I'm back out your body has just a couple
of ways to respond to threats fighting
and fleeing are two of the main ones or
freezing
so think of the same issue
you have a tiger that's been chasing you
your whole life which is shame from
sexual abuse
and probably parents who said hey don't
tell anybody or friends who you kept
secrets from and all the relational
damage that comes out of that stuff
and your wife has a dragons that have
been chasing her forever and in fact
those dragons are still real they're
still right in front of her
in that situation your body chooses to
flee her body chooses to fight
but the underlying
reality is the same
see what I'm saying yeah yeah
and then that that that that
lands in your living room
and you're trying to solve something
that she doesn't want you to solve but
she wants to blame you for something
that you can't have no right it just
gets in this weird figure eight dance
yeah
does that sound right yeah something's
about right yeah okay so I'm getting a
sense that you are being very generous
when you describe your wife as getting
mad at you
yeah
tell me how she expresses herself to you
yes I mean um
to being I mean like
you have spent your whole life defending
other people
okay
be honest about it yeah I will my
promise to you is I will not talk about
about your wife okay okay I won't do
that okay
um but you've got to be honest with me
okay how does she treat you yeah well
um
not good I mean that in some cases where
I try even fleeing doesn't really help
it and sometimes makes it worse right
there will be I mean there were a couple
times where you know the police were
involved and um
screaming she threatening
I was in the vehicle she was driving and
it it got pretty hectic she was driving
records recklessly and it was it was
pretty bad but um
yeah so
at that time I had to find help and the
help that I got was uh it was good but
at the same time it was pretty tense uh
after that because I was away for a
while
uh we were doing marriage counseling but
so hold on you're speaking kind of in
code did you move out for a while
I did move out for a while listen to me
listen to it I believe it was for a few
weeks okay listen I'm not sure that was
the right thing to do and I'm proud of
you
okay
it's the right thing to do
I'm very proud of you it felt wrong
though I know I know I know
I know Shame Shame deep deep deep
unaddressed shame creates these
imaginary duties that we have to
everybody else in the world and then
when we can't fulfill these duties that
aren't even real we then our bodies beat
us up for not being able to solve them
okay
um and I want you to think about this
she has parents that said treat her like
a child still those type of parents
withhold love if the performance by the
kid isn't up to par
so if she doesn't do whatever they say
in the right way she says it regardless
of what it is they ignore her they shun
her they don't invite her they say well
then we're not going out to dinner they
then you can't whatever
and so you have to understand her core
wound the thing deep inside of her is
this person in front of me who says they
love me is gonna leave
um and yeah what your body tells you is
if you get too close to somebody you're
gonna get abused again
and so when somebody comes close to you
you bolt and it's the right thing for
your body and her body screams he's
leaving again and then she goes to war
to which makes you go I gotta get super
the hell out of here and so you see how
each person's trauma is just playing
right into the other ones yeah the only
way this gets healed is one of you has
the courage to turn and stand and stare
it down
and that's what you did that's what
you're doing
what you're doing is really hard
yeah
and I'm super proud of you
thank you doctor it's hard okay now how
can I help you is there a particular
situation or what are you thinking
through what's like uh what's a a thing
that's going on
Okay so
um I just want to
understand how not to uh lash out her
because lately after coming back
um it has gotten better in some cases
but there tends to be that one time
throughout the year or a few times
throughout the year where you know we
get into a big argument yes and I'm
starting to be less and less flighty and
more about fighting not a boy and I
don't I don't like that I know you don't
like it I don't want to go there but you
have to you have to you have to you have
to you have to I know you don't want to
everything in your body says run
but your heart says I love her I'm in
this marriage she's hurting I'm hurting
I'm standing my ground
okay
so how do I so basically I guess my
question is how do I make
um how do I make the arguments less
exposure how do how am I able to control
my feelings from getting in the way to
having a actual adult conversation
that's an um that the fact that you're
asking that question tells me your wise
beyond your years and if every
person in a romantic relationship in the
world would ask that question the world
would change overnight
okay here I'm going to give you a couple
of words that I want you to put in your
back pocket okay and when this call
comes out and and uh I want you to take
it I want you to take a piece of paper
and write down what I'm what I'm saying
okay okay
the first thing is these conversations
have to be done offline
meaning you can't just try to and get
you can't just practice shooting a
basketball when the game is in the
middle of a playoff game
you got to spend time intentional time
at practice for years before the
playoffs because the playoffs have super
heightened tension there's a lot of
people watching there's a lot on the
line here
and so I want you and your wife to step
out and and be honest with each other
your childhood sucked
and then you can look across the table
and say your childhood sucked too
and the Beautiful Thing
is that you all get to choose what
happens next
and so often the exercise of let's take
all money off the table let's take all
the our past abuse off the table let's
take our parents having to come over for
Thanksgiving off the table let's take it
off the table
what do we want our one wild Reckless
crazy marriage to look like
it could be anything we want where do we
want to live what jobs do you want to
have
some fun with that
and you know the things that she loves
whether it's a great meal or flowers or
a weekend getaway whatever it is make it
happen okay
the goal here is to change the
environment and to sit down and say okay
let's create a new picture that we can
both work towards because right now both
of y'all have been running from dragons
and you'll keep crashing into each other
let's go together to something all right
so yeah we're gonna create a new picture
a really high definition picture very
clear we want to live in this place in a
house that looks like this and here's a
the number two
how do you want the house to feel when
you walk in after work
and what we're looking for here is warm
and quiet or hilarious and loud and safe
and silly
okay yeah and what we're going to try to
do is we're going to try to create that
for the other person
yeah so what I like when I walk in
sounds like a dream it does right but
here's the thing here's here's the
number three and this is the big one
that I want you to Circle and highlight
y'all have never done this before and
you've never even seen it done
it feels like a it feels like a Harry
Potter episode like a fantasy it's like
it's not real
and so you're gonna have to practice it
and that means you're going to screw up
a lot
Steph Curry misses shots in practice a
lot of them but he keeps taking him so
that in a game he'll make them
and so what this means is
y'all are gonna go say okay here's what
practicing looks like
when you start yelling
I am choosing to hear that is that
you're done with a conversation I I
choose to not be yelled at so if you
yell you're telling me that you don't
want to engage right now and I'm gonna
head out
and if you want me to stay
then you are going to have to talk to me
with dignity and respect
in a quiet way
and that she gets to tell you
every time you run when I get scared or
I get loud my body feels like I'm being
abandoned again
and so when I get fired up and you feel
me tense
I need you to turn and stay on your
ground
I need you to reach up with both hands
and hold my hands and say I'm not going
anywhere I love you
see what I'm saying yeah what we're
doing here is we're asking the other
person when in a calm situation over
lunch over a breakfast we're in a
romantic place we're hanging out
whatever in a waffle house I don't care
where you are
how can I best love you
when your mom or dad says something that
just sets you off
how can I best love you when you have
super over sexualized thoughts
and you're feeling a lot of Shame
how can I best love you
and let's teach each other and give each
other that language you see what I'm
saying yeah I do yeah does this just
sound I mean does it sound like a like
insane or does it sound like wow this is
amazing
uh I mean it sounds possible it sounds
possible okay uh the third one being the
most probably the hardest but of course
it sounds like it's possible but you see
how it's all a progression so we're
gonna do the easy thing which is what
kind of house we want to live in what
town if we could live in any Town what
would it look like
and we're gonna slowly get back to
you get home from an exhausting day at
work and your mom's been screaming at
you on the phone and you walk in the
door how can I best love you then
and so we're gonna we're gonna go from
easy which is I want a five bedroom
house with three pools and a tiger in
the backyard or whatever all the way to
stuff we've never seen before which is
I just need you to hold me
for two minutes and please don't ask me
any questions
I just need to feel safe right we're
gonna get that granular and then we're
gonna practice it and you're gonna
forget she's gonna come in blowing and
going ah and you're just gonna disappear
and as you're running away You're Gonna
Go
and your body's gonna say get out of
here and you're gonna say I love her I'm
heading back in
or she's gonna come screaming at you
trying to smash something or say I'm
gonna crash this car I'm gonna crash
this car and at the stoplight you're
gonna get out and you're gonna say I
love you and I'm choosing to walk away
right now
and you walk away
but y'all have already discussed that
hey if you choose this I'm choosing this
I see and let me tell you this other
thing that you don't want to hear okay
for the sake of you my friend Alex my
neighbor here in town
for the sake of your marriage
you're gonna have to go see a trauma
counselor
and say for the first time I was
sexually abused when I was a kid my
family did not respond that well
and I'm ready to get I'm ready to seek
healing
yeah okay you have to do that
yeah
and what my promise is is if you get
with a good trauma therapist here in
Nashville there's some incredible
therapists here in town you get in to
see one it's gonna be expensive it's
gonna take a while and that's okay yeah
yeah at the end of it my question would
be like how how many times do I have to
go in and like like what am I supposed
to be doing now I guess make the phone
call and just trust the process
okay trust the process and when you get
there ask that question say I don't
understand how this whole thing works I
think this is weird I think just talking
to you is dumb it's gonna be a waste of
my time a therapist can handle that
they're professional that's their job
okay be honest with them
but here's what we're going for we're
going for that memory that shame that
immediately spins your body up your body
spends all day coming up with these
these um
looping thoughts trying to get a hold of
it these sexualized thoughts these
obsessive behaviors these I mean these
obsessive thoughts these compulsive
behaviors your brain is working all the
time trying to catch up ketchup ketchup
ketchup
what trauma therapy is going to do for
you is you're going to wake up and one
of these thoughts is going to lightning
bolt into your mind and your body's not
going to take off on you
you're not going to feel like you're at
War your heart's not gonna be racing
really fast you're not gonna look around
the room to see if your wife's pissed
off and her body is going to sense that
your body's calm
and so your energy your shame response
your response to abuse from 20 years ago
that your body's still electrified from
your sympathetic nervous system is still
firing and firing and fire and firing
her body's not gonna feel that energy
and start responding
and she's gonna have to have the courage
to tell her parents you don't get a vote
anymore I'm a grown woman
if y'all gonna tell me what to do and
treat me like a kid I'm hanging up the
phone
you don't get to talk to me like that
and if they're paying some of your bills
you all get to decide we're our sanity
and our maturity and our adulthood isn't
worth their money whatever the thing is
right
all this is gonna be about establishing
boundaries and yada all these things are
important but first we're going to start
with you and me are in this together
you and me are in this together what do
we want this thing to look like and I'm
going first I call the counselor I'm
going to get well whatever it takes I'm
worth it and you're worth it and we are
worth it Alex thank you so much for the
call stay on the line I'm going to send
you a copy of own your past change your
future in fact I'm gonna send you two
one for you and one for your wife and I
want you all to go through them together
and then come visit us in the studios if
you ever want to run downtown and hang
out I'd love to meet you in person
appreciate your courage man we'll be
right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right let's go to Amy in Las Vegas
what's up Amy
hi Dr John how are you partying what are
you up to rocking on to bring it on what
are you doing
you're in Vegas
yes
[Laughter]
all right so what's up yeah
yeah
um okay so I have a question for you
um I've been seeing my therapist for
about three years now okay in that time
we've become good friends no no
no oh no
um and I've hung out at our house I've
met her family no run unethical
therapist
right rule number one
I don't even know why I don't know
[Music]
I just totally interrupted you like how
could I help him okay
um so we you know we've done a lot of
stuff together we've hung out no what
kind of therapist dude report this
therapist they should have no license
they should have their license taken
away they are unethical
is it a male or male or female
it's she's a it's a female okay are you
all in a romantic relationship
no no
um so she she the first time she invited
me to her house I was really happy that
she invited me of course
no you're allowed to do whatever you
want you're a grown-up she is not
she is a licensed professional
yeah it's a it's a core violation it's
it's one of the chorus violations
here here's why here's it's called a
dual relationship it's highly unethical
here's why
friendship is the giving and taking of
presence right this back and forth of
love and deep understanding and the
promise
that come what may
all hold your burdens and you'll hold
mine
yeah in a professional therapeutic
relationship is entirely one-sided you
are paying another person to sit with
you in your burdens
there can be there can never be an
expectation or realized the therapist
doing their reverse asking you to hold
her burdens her friendship come to my
house do our things highly manipulative
highly unethical
there should never be contact with the
client listen here's how here's how Wild
it gets
um
I had a client once that was speaking at
an event I was at
and I had a ques nobody in that room
knew nobody
um I I've got colleagues who they they
when they introduce themselves to their
clients they will say if I see here's a
common thing they say this way if I see
you in a grocery store I'm gonna walk
right by you
I will not acknowledge you and it's
going to be weird because you just told
me about all this crazy sex stuff
between you and your husband and your
your boyfriend that you're having an
affair with it's gonna feel weird that
we had these intimate conversations and
I just walked straight past you at a
grocery store
but I'm gonna honor confidentiality so
much I'm gonna honor the professional
relationship so firmly now you can go
run up and hug your therapist and be
like I don't care that's fine you're
allowed to do that
um and then once you breach that that
boundary you can hug and say hi whatever
um
but dude it is I I mean I can't tell you
how wrong that is
so there's no situation where that would
be appropriate I think
it's been a while since I I the the
counseling um code of ethics
um I think is five years
after the last session
can you have a relationship and I think
the APA it's been a while since I read
that one but I think that one is never
but I've been a homie to that one but
it's at least an extended period of time
after you write your last check and you
have your last session
highly highly unprofessional
okay I think
I think part of the reason is because
she's a she's an unethical professional
that's the only reason that's the only
reason okay what are you gonna say I was
rude
well she knows that I don't have any
other friends
um and I have a toxic family that I'm
currently
um distancing myself from and I don't
know if she's doing it as a way to try
and help me
um she knows my situation
um and I I just don't know if that's why
she's doing it or she just
I don't know but um I mean she I I would
I would not
um so in Psychology it's called the
fundamental attribution error
where you get inside someone else's head
and try to decide why they're doing
whatever it is they're doing
I would not do that I'd get out of her
head
because even if she's trying to help
what she should be doing okay let's just
use this this example what she should be
doing is teaching you in session
how to be uncomfortable how to ask okay
you want to go hang out and grab coffee
hey let's make a plan for you're gonna
invite three women that you don't know
that well that you work with but you're
gonna invite them over for whatever is
going on
um and then she's gonna be a safe place
for you to go back to during your next
session after the thing is the party's a
disaster or after it goes great
and she's so her job is to teach you
skills and then send you out into the
wild
and in the counseling session you get to
practice those skills the beautiful
thing about the counselor client
relationship is it mimics the real world
it's a safe place for you somebody who's
struggling with relationships someone
who's struggling with a toxic family to
practice
heading back out into the real world
it's unethical when she follows you out
into the real world and says hey hold on
you can't really do this I'll take this
for you and in the same time meets her
own needs by using you
well the thing is she has been such a
godsend to me she's helped me through
the worst times in my life and I I
really value both her friendship and her
expertise as a therapist I just don't
want to lose her
um
I mean I I just I don't I I really enjoy
spending time with her of course you do
of course you do
that's in in quite honestly that's the
problem
I'm gonna use a um I'm gonna use an
analogy that may may not fit may not be
fair but it's the one coming to mind
okay
imagine a buddy of mine tell he's
sitting down and telling me how amazing
his wife is
she loves me
she shows up for me
she listens to me the sex is
unbelievable
like I love my wife
and then
our other buddy at the table says I pay
a woman for sex
I pay her for her time and her
relationship and her interaction
and she listens to me and we talk and we
hang out she invites me over
one of those sounds right and one of
those sounds disgusting
you see what I'm saying
you're you're paying her
I just I know I mean it's unethical
because it's like a one-sided
conversation
a one-sided thing
I'm saying it's unethical because she's
violating the code of ethics or for the
profession
she is hopefully is licensed and
shouldn't be much longer
she's got a very vulnerable person who's
struggling with family Dynamics who's
struggling with loneliness
and she is using that person a for money
B to fill whatever needs she's filling
even if it's she needs to feel like she
can solve everybody else's problems
and she can make people feel not so bad
about themselves it's not her job her
job is to walk alongside you
teach you skills hold you accountable
call you out
and care for you as you head out into
the into your world
yeah you see what I'm saying and I this
is I can't imagine how heartbreaking
this is for you which is why I'm so
upset about it
well I think I knew what the answer was
but I I think I just needed to hear it
out loud you know
I think you're being used
and I think you're worth more than that
just listening to you I think you would
be a great friend
and I bet you're loyal to a fault aren't
you
oh yeah the world needs more people like
you as friends
I think part of me feels like
I'm not going to be able to find quote
unquote real friends out there so I I'm
kind of attached to her
and that's her job is to not let you get
that attached to her and she failed you
I'm sorry
yeah
her job is to that discomfort you feel
that fear because your family didn't
didn't show up for you when they should
have your other friends have have
haven't shown up for you have you had um
romantic relationships go sideways
I have yeah so you've got a lifelong
history train tracks of relational pain
and what her job is is to sit with you
in the discomfort not try to take it
away for you
and she tried she took it away from you
and she charged you for it
and so in a way she robbed you of the
opportunity to go out and practice
making friends screw it up be awkward be
weird learn about yourself learn about
what your value is and over time
basically here's what she did you went
and got a personal trainer
and you paid her and she lifts the
weights for you every time y'all y'all
lift
and then when it's over you're not very
strong
and you don't feel confident because you
know you didn't lift any weight
but it was awesome to see that much
weight on the bar
see what I'm saying yeah that makes
sense
well do you think
um I think you should never see her
again you should file on her license in
the state of Nevada is what I think
you think even if I stop seeing her as a
therapist that I
thought without a friend
I think you're a grown-up and you can do
whatever you want
when I run into unethical
I mean I I guess I don't hang out with
guys like that
like one of my closest buddies in the
world his name is John King he's an
amazing friend and he is the CEO of an
HR he's a chief exist he's not a CEO but
he he's a senior leader in an HVAC
company
If he if we were just having drinks one
night and he told me he was like man I I
like to charge extra here and here and
rip these people I wouldn't hang out
with him
yeah like I don't I don't want those
people in my life my friends aren't like
that
I think I'm just having trouble
um figuring it out or understanding
ly it's unethical
I go go back in here go back and listen
to call and because I walk you through
it and what you're gonna start doing is
you're gonna spiral because she's been
your only she's been come she's become
your oxygen tank
[Music]
and she gosh
how about this have her call me
have her call the show I'd love to talk
to her
let's do that
and you can just be a fly on the wall
for that conversation she won't call but
[Music]
there's there's the Dare Amy's therapist
you unethical shouldn't have a license
shut up we'll be right back
show is sponsored by better help folks
take a minute to think about how much
time you spend on yourself it's easy to
get caught up in what people need from
you and want from you and never think
about what you need and then you end up
too stretched out burned out all of the
madness of our current world resting on
your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
Raleigh North Carolina and talk to Jade
what's up Jade
yeah I mean I could not be better how
are you good good
what's up
so um I guess just get straight to the
point Cannonball
yeah I've been doing really good in my
life I'm in a healthy relationship I've
like gone into a positive direction
but for some reason I just could never
forgive myself for all the bad decisions
I've made in the past and I just feel
like I'm just always angry with myself
what'd you do
um so I got into a really bad
relationship that kind of like destroyed
everything
like my family it destroyed me
financially I married him knowing that
like he had a baby with my friend he was
always you know hiding things behind my
back lying to me and just doing like
there's like so many red flags of why I
should have never been with him
and you know I finally made the decision
after I married him to divorce him
because I just couldn't take the
emotional
um mental abuse anymore the financial
abuse and I'm in a better like place
with my life now but every single time
like I do something well I'm like wow I
could have done this such a long time
ago if I had never made those bad
decisions and you would not be you would
not be near
the gangster that you are right now if
you had not been through that
yeah I don't really feel like that
sometimes I don't feel like very
very I know
who taught you in your life that when
you're abused it's your fault
somebody taught you that yeah well how
did she teach you that
well like even if I could do everything
right and if something happens wrong she
finds some way to have even though like
I could have done everything to prevent
that from happening if just something
happens wrong it's like you should have
done X Y and Z better you should have
done this and I've kind of always felt
like
if I am not perfect or if I don't find a
way to make sure there is no mistakes
that are just I'm just a complete
failure
and somehow over time her constant
criticism and critique and negativity
you've probably heard me use this
analogy but you were born with a
backpack a beautiful little girl where
were you born
um I was born in Okinawa Japan okay
beautiful little girl in Okinawa
and make sure where your States the
states
and your mom just keeps dropping little
pebbles in your backpack every day why
are you wearing that you're too fat
don't fix your hair like that it makes
you look ugly you have a big forehead
and I'm and I'm just making stuff up
I've never seen you but just never stops
why did you do this is this the best you
can you couldn't have got a hundred you
just got a 98 that's stupid right little
Pebble little Pebble little pebble
and after a while that backpack gets
really freaking heavy doesn't it
yeah and after a while her words become
your words
so when you talk that way to yourself
that's not your voice that's your mom's
voice
Fair
yeah
now how many years ago was did you start
this relationship with this dude
so he was actually my high school
sweetheart so I've been with him for a
long time before I finally broke it off
because I just how old was he couldn't
handle it how old was he um
when we first met we were in our we were
in our teenage years and then finally
when we separated what was great about
him when you met him
like was he cute was he funny was he
silly
yeah all of that
okay
were you 16 14 how old were you
I was 15. 15.
here's homework assignment number one
I want you to write 15 year old Jade a
letter a handwritten letter with no book
paper and a pen
I want you to forgive her let her go she
was a kid
okay
if you met a 15 year old little girl how
old are you now
I'm 28. you met a 15 year old girl
who was just beating herself up because
her boyfriend was slowly taking her soul
from her
and taking her innocence from her and
was slowly controlling her and she was
just telling you what a terrible
girlfriend she is what would you say to
her
that she shouldn't be in that
relationship yeah and you tell her hey
you're a kid chill out
you need to tell 15 year old Jade
but that boy was cute and that boy was
funny and she acted like every other 15
year old girl
and she had a crush on him and she went
on a date with him and then she fell in
love with him
and nobody could have predicted the
quicksand that you would have ended up
in
an abuse and Trauma and gaslighting and
psychosis all those things
wreak havoc on people
we find ourselves doing things we would
never do just to keep the peace for a
minute just to keep safety just to keep
whatever
and then your second letter I want you
to write
how old were you when you broke up with
this dude when you got divorced
um I was
about I was talking I think 26. okay I
want you to write 26 year old Jada
letter and tell her how proud of her you
are
for getting the courage to stand up for
getting the courage just to walk away
from getting the current from all of it
and be very specific in that letter you
did this and you did this
good for you
and then here's my big question for you
is any of this constant beating up on
yourself
you talk to yourself in a way that you
would never let somebody talk to another
person that you love
if somebody at a bar talk to one of your
girlfriends the way you talk to yourself
you would hit them in the mouth with a
beer bottle right I know you
so my question is is any of this
self-talk helping
is any of this helping you get where you
want to be
no okay it just upsets me and just I
just kicked down on myself even more
cause from the earliest age you can
remember
the one person who was supposed to be in
your corner all the time
declared war on you
and from as early as you can remember
the first guy who looked at you and said
I love you and I'll be here forever
was a piece of crap
yeah so it's easy for your body to think
oh this is what I'm worth all across the
board the most important woman my first
love all you see what I'm saying
so what you have to decide is
I'm done with this
Jade is an absolute gangster who's been
through hell and back and I got the
scars to prove it bring it on world
and Mom if you're going to continue to
criticize me then you are choosing to
not be in relationship with this
gangster
bye Felicia
hey new boyfriend
if you get an
ounce of dishonesty dude I'm a smoke
show I'm awesome I'm Jade
bye Felicia
right and when Jade starts talking to
Jade really bad negatively
I want you to keep a little Journal once
you start writing that crap down
and I want you to physically write it
down and physically draw life a line
through it and right underneath it lies
not true
or occasionally I probably shouldn't
eaten two uh McGriddles Fair all right
that's fair
you could Circle that one and say true
all right
all right so I just talked a lot at you
tell me how you're feeling
um you feel a bit better about it um I
guess
I got kind of worried that like a lot of
these habits that I've kind of
picked up from all of that is kind of
like entering into my new relationship
too and I just don't want that to
transition there because I'm trying to
remember that he's not my ex and it's
really hard for me so like here's the
way here's a way to overcome it
keep no secrets
here's what that means
does this new boyfriend this is the new
person you're in a relationship with do
they know all your past
yeah okay so I want you to take them out
and say I like you have you said I love
you gross
yeah
I don't want to wait all right so I want
you to take him out and say I love you
and I find in finding myself falling
into Old patterns
I'm not gonna allow that to happen again
and if you love me you're gonna walk
alongside me here's what this means this
means I'm gonna have to practice
if you catch me with negative self-talk
I I'm asking you to call it up
if you at see me withdrawing I'm gonna
ask you to reach out and grab my hand
and say I love you whatever it is that
you need in those moments
I want you to speak those needs out and
when you speak those needs out you're
going to feel buck naked in in this and
on on the Taylor Swift stage in front of
all these you can feel so exposed right
because nobody's ever given a crap what
you need or want or feel
right and it's time
but you can't expect them to if you're
not going to give yourself that
are you in
yeah I'm definitely gonna try not to be
as mean to myself no no
better than that
I'm freaking Jade
and I want a reckless hilarious fun
marriage
drama free
I want a job that's not toxic
I want adult relationships that aren't
stupid
and I'm worth all that
Fair
Fair what's your favorite charity in the
world like what's what's a what's a
thing that's near and dear to your heart
the domestic violence awareness
do you have a local chapter there in
Raleigh
yeah we do we have like a women's
shelter that usually helps them
okay
um
will you make me a deal here on the
radio
yeah say I promise
I promise oh this is amazing you're such
a sucker I can't believe you said yes to
this okay every time every time you talk
negative to Jade you have to send them a
dollar
every time
yeah I could do that okay
it's gonna cost you money
cool
yeah you have to put some roadblocks up
between your automated response
whether that's a behavior whether that's
an action whether it's grabbing a drink
or grabbing a cigarette or running away
and you're going to ore between your
thoughts
here's a funny example that's not so
funny and I'm not proud of it but it
just is I
um
I have a buddy who wants to drink less
and I have a like I eat way too much
junk food
so I put a thousand dollars on the table
one thousand bucks the first person
um he has a drink or if I grab junk food
a thousand dollars the first person to
Blink the other person's got to pay
and I figured out really quickly I'm so
mindless I just reach over there's candy
everywhere here there's junk food and
donuts everywhere here at work and
everywhere I go my house it's Easter
good con and I just grab it
and so I started to grab it one the very
first time right after I made this this
deal I reached over to grab it and I was
by myself and I just flipped it off
I gave it to bird
and then it made me laugh because I was
just trying to say like no I took a
picture of it and I texted it to him
and then every time I started mindlessly
grabbing it it was making me laugh I
would give it the bird and I'd take a
picture of it and text it to him
and in about a week
I quit grabbing it
what I needed was something just like
it's just called mindfulness I needed
something to stop my automated response
you suck
there's a dollar I'm Vin mowing the the
women's shelter
he's gonna get so mad if you there's a
dollar I'm sitting in the venmo I mean
I'm sitting in the shelter
can't believe you're so stupid you're
late there's another dot right I'm gonna
put these little roadblocks in front of
me
so that I can begin to catch myself in
this automated responses and you're
gonna have to decide I'm gonna quit
carrying this crap around
are you done carrying it Jade
yeah I really am I promise
I promise
tell this boy that you're dating
you're about to get a whole new woman
I'm gonna be fun and we're gonna be
goofy and we're going dancing
everything's changing
and it's gonna be a bumpy shot out of
the gate it's gonna we're gonna have to
figure this out and practice it but
we're changing it all we're changing all
of it because I'm Jade and I want a
different world I want a different life
or a different life
if that means you gotta cut people out
of your life good that means you have to
add new people in your life good
whatever it takes Jade you're worth that
and
everything good you got coming for you
you've been through hell and back and
you got the scars
now I want you to stand up and realize
how strong and how tall you are
and how awesome whatever's coming next
can be
if you make some hard choices and some
hard changes you're worth it we'll be
right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right hey uh Kelly's out today her
mother-in-law passed away I mean she's
just had a rough uh last six months or
so
um so if you'll keep Kelly in your
prayers
um think about her as she's down there
taking care of her family and uh but
that means that Jenna is behind the
board today as the producer of the show
and that means of course we're doing a
Taylor Swift song to end the day
absolutely
I'm most likely be a Taylor Swift song
it's
so is basically the Taylor Swift
with special guest John deloney show
the song is called this is me trying
I've been having a hard time adjusting I
had the shiniest wheels and now they're
rusting gosh that's
Taylor's Rhymes dude they are like
jay-z-esque
I didn't know if you'd care if I came
back I have a lot of regrets about that
pulled the car off the road to the
lookout could have followed my tears all
the way down and maybe I don't quite
know what to say but I'm here in your
doorway oh my gosh that was awesome all
that stuff and she ended up at his house
well done t-swift I just wanted you to
know this is me trunk oh my gosh this so
good this is me trying
this America y'all don't need this show
just listen to T Swift and everything
will be better love you guys
[Music]